it was the 90s people had a different
mentality like everything was you wanted
to do well Bill Murray went on there and
just did what Bill Murray used to do
which was this Bill Murray's tone was
never heard before he did it in the
1978. nobody ever saw this tone in
comedy just like Richard Bells Richard
Bell's a stand-up was not that great but
nobody he invented okay babe sure nobody
did that before I never saw it and then
people in the streets were doing it not
just Comedians and Bill Murray used to
go like now listen to me guy and he had
this ironic weird thing he did these
characters like this movie review it was
just a whole different tone than you'd
ever seen in comedy or in life how many
people have you seen do that like were
they how were they completely unique
um I can't think of that many I mean
those those I mean I would say Bill
Murray chained like everybody was funny
in different ways and they were all
unique on Saturday Night Live to a
degree but Bill Murray I'll tell you
another one I haven't seen even though
it's based on something real but it's
it's a guy calm on succession right
that's unique yeah tone just that you
don't see the English actor McFadden
yeah he's brilliant he's doing this
crazy guy right that's like it's
completely you've never seen a character
quit like that but Bill Murray did like
five characters on on SNL at that time
he did the ship like that cruise like
you know people always make fun of like
this Lounge singer the oily Lounge
singer right he nobody did that before
him right nobody did it with that tone
the way he used to do it and I feel like
Norm had that space yeah nobody perfect
example right Norm's tone was
distinctive and unique yes and nobody
did that nobody did what Norm did you
know what I mean I talked about Norma in
the show too it's funny but and one of
the things is no one would talk people
like we talked to some strange way you
know small talking people and be like
and then the guy like you're right I'm
quitting a job and he'd walk out and
then oh my go to me I didn't tell him to
quit that job like yes you did but he
like no whole world was not just me he
was making fun of you you were part of
this the suckers too yeah yeah you'd be
like I mean you're telling me you know
you just bring you into that brilliant
podcast he had with Adam hegan yes yeah
well I went to Norm's uh uh
you know his uh memorial service yeah
Anatomy gets spoke and he killed it was
all these professional experience he had
to be coming up and he goes I love Norm
Macdonald even though if you Google me
today it says Holocaust denier Adam Egan
that's the first thing
and he went on about normal but it was
yeah and without him it was perfect
because the guest didn't know that I
like half the gas nowhere to go I mean I
agree with you not like this guy thinks
the Holocaust didn't happen and it gets
to be look you could see the Angry Eyes
like what and Adam would just sit there
and take it and I guess would leave the
show thinking this guy's a holocaust
denied
yeah there was nothing funnier than when
Norm yeah was like yeah this guy [__]
this is the Holocaust happen so fun and
just blow past it and the guess would
look you could see them looking and then
Norm would move on brilliant yes Norm
would just keep going and then yeah
would you sneak a look at him like what
the [__] yeah and it was and Adam to his
credit did
sometimes you try to deny it usually
just take
that's something